the original draft of Attack on Titan
was created in 2006 and it was a story
where Aaron didn't exist the walls
didn't exist and Titans were even more
impossible to kill initially the idea
was submitted to weakly Shonen Jump
which is the famous magazine that at the
time was publishing series like Naruto
death note and of course one piece which
is still going on like most submissions
the first draft of Attack on Titan was
rejected but despite that there were
other people who saw the potential in
this video what we're about to do is
examine the original story from 2006 and
by the end you'll see what Attack on
Titan could have looked like if the
series has stuck to its original Vision
on top of that I'll also be showing you
all the moments that ended up getting
reused in the main series including one
major plot twist alright so the original
Draft starts off with this Titan as it
approaches a group of terrified looking
soldiers seconds later it then begins
eating them one by one and while that's
happening we get an interesting
backstory about how these monsters were
created a hundred years earlier there
was some kind of man made Global crisis
and following that a group of scientists
and religious people decided that they
had to do something in order to protect
themselves they began the mankind
destruction operation with the hope of
eradicating every other human on the
planet as part of this operation they
engineered the Titans from scratch
although these Titans are completely
different to the ones we know from the
anime in the original draft every Titan
had the power to shapeshift into the
form of someone they've eaten purely as
an example imagine that when Marco was
eaten in season 1 the Titan that did it
suddenly transformed into him and then
just pretended to be Marco for the next
few years in the first draft the Titans
had this ability making it significantly
easier to infiltrate humanity and as if
that by itself wasn't bad enough they
didn't even have a typical weak spot in
their neck instead the Titan's only
weakness was a special organ called the
nucleus which was always randomly
located somewhere inside the Tyson's
body in this opening scene of the manga
nearly every lost Soldier is killed
before they can find the nucleus with
the only Survivor being a soldier called
murakumo as a character mirakumo is
similar to Levi when it comes to his
physical strength but in terms of design
he has a few things in common with
Mikasa and Aaron anyway In This Moment
he tries to Ambush the Titan BY
attacking it from behind but at the last
second it turns around leaving him in a
life or death situation the story then
flashes forward by a month where it
revealed that Humanity lives inside
towns that are surrounded by large trees
if you're wondering why it's because the
scientists who created Titans didn't
want to hurt the environment and so they
programmed Titans to view nature as
sacred while presumably viewing humans
is evil as a result their programming
doesn't allow them to destroy trees
explaining why the forest acts as a
barrier defending Humanity now in this
particular town murakumo is seen walking
down the street and as he looks around
he notices that all the locals are
afraid of him one thing you need to know
about this character is that he's a
member of the Vanguard which is the only
branch of the military that goes outside
the trees therefore none of the locals
actually saw what happened between
murakumo and the Titan all they know is
that a Vanguard Squad was wiped out and
apparently this guy was the only
Survivor from their point of view you
can understand why that doesn't sound
realistic and in their minds it's more
likely that the entire Squad was killed
and that the man standing in front of
them is a shape-shifting Titan in fact
even murakumo himself seems to not be a
hundred percent certain about what he is
now however there is one person who
believes that he's a normal human as you
can tell from her appearance this
character is literally Gabby which is
what I'm going to be calling her for the
rest of the video although just so you
know her name in the original draft is
Tsubaki in terms of her backstory when
she was younger her dad was eaten alive
by a Titan and ever since then it's been
her goal to join the Vanguard and get
revenge for that reason she's been
begging murakumo to train her for the
past month since unlike the rest of the
town she doesn't believe that he's a
shape-shifting demon in spite of that he
initially refuses to turn her into a
soldier but as they keep talking we find
out that Gabby's dad was one of miracle
Kuma's old friends on top of that he
knows how she feels because 10 years ago
his own dad was eaten by a Titan as well
and so in the end he does agree to train
her if she practices swinging her blade
a hundred times every day soon
afterwards mirakumo then leaves to work
in another part of town and as he walks
through the crowd he's quickly
surrounded by a group of highly trained
soldiers these soldiers are known as
their fifth unit which is the squad that
has the greatest military strength and
their mission is to find out if there's
a Titan pretending to be a human earlier
on when Gabby kept talking to murakumo
the entire time that was happening he
was busy trying to fix this broken radio
once he eventually got it working his
Superior officer takanami asked if they
could switch places because he secretly
wanted to access the radio for himself
takanami then used the device to call
the fifth unit and he requested that
they come to this town since like
everyone else he suspected that murakumo
is a Titan that's why they all surround
him in this town center and the soldiers
quickly ordered him to drop his weapons
interestingly though at first murakumo
seemed seemed kind of shocked and Afraid
about the situation but after looking at
all the fifth unit members his facial
expression turns to anger as takanami
begins to wonder what's going on
mirakumo then whips out his sword and
thanks to this special mechanism the
blade catches fire he then uses his
flaming Katana to literally slice
through one of the fifth unit soldiers
cutting them in half which is one
example of his crazy physical strength
in response the civilians all run away
thinking that mirakumo must be a Titan
but in reality the reason he did what he
did is because the person he slice is an
imposter earlier I mentioned how
murakuma's father was eaten 10 years ago
which is why in the present day he got
so angry when he saw a fake version of
his dad as a member of the fifth unit
his father's body then abruptly
transforms into a giant obese Titan and
it's revealed that in this world Titans
can make themselves larger by eating
other Titans what that means is that the
obese Titan must have eaten its own kind
to get that big and as mirakumo goes to
sound the alarm the other members of the
fifth unit turn into Titan's as well
this shows that at some point in the
past Humanity's strongest soldiers were
defeated and replaced by the enemy and
pretty soon these smaller Titans then
start eating the larger one while
they're busy with that mirakumo gets
ready for the battle although takanami
tells him that they should abandon this
town and head over to the nearest city
by themselves if they were to do that it
would mean leaving behind Gabby and all
of the locals but takanami believes
there's no other way to save themselves
in his mind Humanity can't win against
the Titans especially considering that
even the fifth Unit were taken down
regardless miracumo declares that
mankind can win this fight and to me
this scene reminds me of two different
moments from their main series the first
scene came in episode 4 when Thomas took
on a similar role to takanami only for
Aaron to take on the role of murakumo as
he passionately explains why they have a
chance separately in chapter 12 of the
main manga there was this panel where
Aaron was presented to a crowd of
soldiers by Commander Pixis and Visually
speaking it does look the same with the
main difference being that mirakumo's
hairstyle is more closer to Mikasa
anyhow on the battlefield Gabby shows up
to single-handedly face the Titans by
herself armed with two kitchen knives
and nothing else almost immediately her
behavior catches the attention of one of
the Titans and as it launches towards
her mirakumo swoops in to save her at
the last second following that he orders
her to stay behind while he goes to
fight the Titan and as that's going on
takanami stays Frozen in fear given that
he's the superior officer takanami gets
angry with himself for being so scared
of the enemy gradually his rage builds
up to the point where he forces himself
to join the battle and soon afterwards
murakumo finds the Titan's nucleus
attack an army then deals the finishing
Blow by creatively using his weapon to
shoot fire straight through the Titan's
weak spot exploding its nucleus in the
process from a distance Gabby watches on
thinking that these two soldiers can
save the town but before she can
properly celebrate another Titan jumps
forward and kills takanami besides the
fact that this was an incredibly
traumatizing moment things somehow
managed to get even worse when she
Witnesses the Titan grabbing murakumo at
first it squeezes his body till he
coughs up blood exactly like what
happened to Aaron's mother in their main
series and then it slowly brings him
towards his mouth while Gabby watches
this sequence was definitely the
blueprint for what ended up going down
in episode 1. although you could argue
the draft version is even worse
considering that Gabby already lost a
parent to the Titans and now it's just
you know adding insult to injury by
seeing her teacher get ripped to shreds
as well that being said after biting
murakuma's head off you'd expect that
this would be the end of things and that
the Titans would just destroy the town
but somehow the remaining part of his
body uses its Katana to slice off the
Titan's hand in this panel we can
clearly see that the whole right side of
murakumo is missing but the left side
swung the blade as if it was still alive
all of a sudden miracumo then resurrects
from the dead as his head and torso
regenerates completely and in the blink
of an eye he fully transforms into the
attack Titan in that sense the draft
version and the main series share the
same plot twist of the MC coming back to
life as a Titan shifter although the one
small change is that this original Titan
can speak which isn't something Aaron
was ever able to do in this form
regardless following his transformation
miracumu starts to have flashbacks to
the time when he faced off against that
Titan in the beginning just like the
locals predicted he was eaten in the
same way as the other Vanguard soldiers
but inside the Titan stomach he was
still alive as a quick side note before
we continue what's amazing about this
panel is that isayama decided to
recreate it in chapter 117 which came
out a whole 13 years after the original
draft in any case after eating murakumo
the Titan began to scream as its body
melted away and when it finally
disappeared the only thing left was a
fully regenerated murakumo this is very
similar to what happened with Zeke in
part two of the final season in that the
Titan's own flesh was used to recreate
the person inside it but the reason this
happened to murakumo is way different to
anything we've seen in the anime but
I'll explain it at their end of the
video for now all you need to know is
that the Titan disintegrated because it
ate murakumo and now in the present day
he has the power to shapeshift into his
own version of the attack Titan he then
proceeds to go on a crazy Titan killing
rampage that must have been the
prototype for Aaron's Rampage and trust
and things are going well until one of
the Titans attacks him from behind
murakumo then has his arm completely
ripped off revealing the nucleus in his
left shoulder but he does manage to kill
the Titan before it can damage his weak
spot with that done only one of the
fifth unit Titans was still standing and
luckily for murakumo its own nucleus was
visible for everyone to see as long as
this final Titan could be destroyed then
the entire time would be saved but the
problem is that the Titan has seen
murakumo's weak spot as well
unfortunately he then wasn't fast enough
to react to that information and his
nucleus gets crushed when the last
remaining Titan bites down in it
whenever the nucleus is destroyed the
Titan starts melting away almost
immediately after and so realizing that
he's about to die murakuma retaliates by
using the last of of his energy to
destroy the other times weak spot as
well this causes them to both melt away
one after the other and in my opinion
this panel here is reminiscent of the
iconic moment from chapter 100 when
Aaron was about to crush Willy Tiber I
do find it interesting though that even
with all that time passing there are
certain moments from the original draft
that he keeps referring back to
throughout the story and another one is
Gabby's eyes in this panel like we all
know we've seen this a hundred times
Aaron doing this exact expression anyway
moving on to the end the original draft
gives us an explanation for how mirakumo
initially gained his Titan Powers as we
know a hundred years ago Titans were
programmed to see nature as sacred and
pure-hearted and as a consequence
pure-hearted things aren't allowed to be
destroyed this programming created a
loophole in which pure-hearted people
like mirakumo couldn't be absorbed
explaining why that first Titan
involuntarily gave its life to
regenerate him back to normal in
situations like this the Titan's power
transfers to the human and according to
Gabby it was the first time that humans
have successfully fought back against
their enemy in her Town specifically the
locals had built this gravestone to
commemorate murakumo's sacrifice
although Gabby was upset that they never
actually got to train in spite of that
it is still her goal to become the
strongest soldier in the Vanguard and so
after wiping away the tears she gets
ready to swing her blade a hundred times
just like he told her to do with that
said that was the original draft of
Attack on Titan and as you can tell
there were a ton of elements from this
that did make it into the main series
but also some other things that were
drastically changed one of the things I
liked about the draft is how the Titan's
ability to shapeshift into humans it
meant that the civilians were basically
always on edge and that makes things a
little bit more interesting when you
contrast it to episode 1 where humans
had gotten a little bit too comfortable
with their position another thing that
was cool is the way murakuma regenerated
his head and also the right side of his
body usually it's a lot more of a slow
gradual process I think this would have
looked amazing in animated form just an
entire like half of a body coming back
to life in a split second it just I
think that would look really cool let me
know in the comments down below what
were the things in this draft that you
thought were interesting or surprising
and as always don't forget to like this
video as it does help out the channel if
you're feeling generous then I'd
appreciate it if you also subscribe to
the channel and share this video with a
friend and until the next one peace out